good morning Mike how are you hey DP man
how are you man how's everybody over
there every everything is great did you
watch the tebow workout yesterday and if
you did your thoughts people looks like
a he's been lifting weights yes he does
he look good actually you know and guys
it was a smart guy you know and the man
lost the game of baseball I don't see
anything wrong with with him trying out
doing what he's doing now you may get
upset at the number of people they
showed up to watch him try out but I
don't think you can get upset at him for
trying out oh no I you can do it if
nobody showed up you know then they
probably would have put out a video but
you had all the two teams show up so
what's it say about those teams that
they showed up to see Tim Tebow work out
and I would sign him I'd put him in my
minor leagues and don't let him take
advantage of it the marketing ploy I'd
have no problem he looked girdle man he
looked like even playing you know
hitting that weight room and working
hard and everything I don't think I've
ever seen why yes i did Canseco was
being like that Jose was pretty big dude
like that hit that ball pretty good yam
it can sink it was artificially inflated
how is that some kind of uh some kind of
rumor you put that right there no no oh
no not about Tebow I'm time I can sink
oh okay okay I okay I Protoceratops
oregano Tebow it looks like he's all
natural there now the Vikings need a
quarterback what's that say about Tim
Tebow that they're not even calling him
give him a chance to maybe come in Oh
first let's go this route here on the
riders need a quarterback man i feel so
or before or ibly for for it pity and no
of you know and Jim over there those are
my guys you know I know those guys have
been doing a wonderful job in Minnesota
arm getting that young team in position
i add him as my surprise team last year
and i thought they would do some pretty
good things
sheer especially after getting Treadwell
in the draft I told him when he got
drafted I said man you're going to love
them in a soda you're going to be Norse
Turner Nora Turner's new microwave and
you'll run that bang eight and
everything is just you know to see
pretty girls go down like that man it it
just you know it really it really sad
you're really sad for have you ever had
one of those injuries in front of you a
teammate like you had guys who are
physically sick when they saw Teddy with
dislocate his knee you ever have yeah
yeah well you know of course I I myself
of that knee surgery me on ACL but what
they were describing what I've heard no
no I've never really seen anything like
that you know that that that that kind
of way to will make you almost throw up
on the football field but but you know
and everybody loves teddy man I mean
this kid yeah and I mean you better if
you're around this kid this is one of
the greatest kids when the greatest
dudes you would ever want to be around
you know I get on them all the time for
skipping out on us at Miami but he's
just a great kid you really feel bad for
him I know he had a big season plan to
editing and now you just want to pray
for his recovery who is the best athlete
you were ever around probably Dr Sanders
the best natural athlete I mean
physically gifted person that I've ever
been around is probably Deion Sanders I
mean Dion was great baseball player
baseball played football very very good
basketball player you know I've been in
dunk contest with alma maters of
physical physically gifted freak is what
he was what about Bo Johnson yeah Bobo
was great too but I wasn't as close to
bow when you say around you know I know
blow out bow yes not the kind of time I
spent around beyond well beyond is just
there was a beast Dion talks about when
he was trying to tackle bow and bow put
his hand he said he's like he blessed me
put a put his hand on my forehead and
then just basically pushed him to the
ground like you know I'm gonna heal you
now go to go to the ground and get away
from me and this is deon describing it
he said
you know I I wanted no part of bull
Jackson deal we'll talk to me about
covering somebody I want to use
described to me about that to somebody
okay you know i could get back those few
minutes of my life is a michael irvin
the playmaker joining a stamp patrick
show the cowboys situation with Tony
Romo now out so they're super bowl odds
went from 17 21 to 31 but morale is a
little bit higher there than a lot more
higher there than it is in Minnesota
with dak Prescott have you seen enough
where you can say dak Prescott the
cowboys are in good hands well I I saw
another atom of them in college and then
I I tell everybody our God then i
bragged about this and you know every
now and then I like to say I told you so
and hopefully and I'm gonna hit that on
this make sure he proves me right again
but I bet it was the best quarterback in
the drive I just started a physical gift
I mean is this kid could playing Ron
smart his poor boys I told Jerry bet
that's why i SAT with him that first
preseason game as you know I spent the
whole preseason games and I told you so
I saw you saw and I was trying to
convince nearly being just not go get
one of these old joke goes that lose
every time they step on the football
field one of these old veterans let's
stick with this young guy because the
team is believing in him and give him
this opportunity I didn't expect for
this opportunity to happen so quickly
like this i really wanted Tony Romo to
get an opportunity to show the world
really what he is and I thought this
would be a great year for Tony Romo so
hopefully that can keep you keep the
ship right where he needs it until tony
and gets back but i love this kid dan I
think it was the better the best
quarterback in interact last year but
you had Jerry Jones he was doing his
best to go after Paxton Lynch and you
know thought about Carson Wentz if he
fell and then you know he was he was
looking at a variety of quarterbacks it
was like dak fell into their lap they
tried to screw it up Purcell
ready try to screw it up but I told them
beautiful some pre-work like that the
best things sometimes work like that you
know you had just started mind at this
part of mine you hear from all of these
people and the reality is your father at
that Prescott and it's the blessing in
disguise you know that that believes
that he is he believes he's the best
quarterback and then we have to sit
around to a fourth round do you know
what kind of spunk that puts in you to
go out and prove the whole world wrong
so the jury tried to get the Paxton
Lynch's and all of that but the fact
that that had to sit around this guy
will use that of energy you gotta steal
and do exactly what he's been doing in
too preachy we talked about this
yesterday with Calvin Johnson joining
Dancing with the Stars calvin johnson
hall of famer is there not a surprise
wait a minute let's get back to dancing
with the stars that's a surprise to see
Calvin Johnson say yes I mean to Dancing
with the Stars I can't wait to watch
that I see an Alabama Roger am i what is
he a Hall of Famer hi I think he put up
some great numbers Great Hall of Fame
numbers now here again and you know the
thing is do you start assessing wing
towards all of Famers it's just an
individual status it's the individual
thing absolutely I think he'll have a
chance and he certainly should get in
the Hall of thing well you know Detroit
man it's just so bill Barry Sanders got
in and they never really want and are
offered numbers I think Calvin is
certainly getting here Colin Kaepernick
is going to start in San Diego on
Thursday night how does this play out
this season Mike I I don't think it all
goes very well I me when you think about
it first of all first of all starting in
San Diego with all with all of our
military and personnel out of San Diego
that's going to be that's going to be an
interesting start but but I just don't
think this is going to play that well it
brings a lot of distract
to a team that's already distracted and
not very good and it's going to do a lot
of losing now you Eric this element on
to that then that [ __ ] is going to be
a part it's going to be a tough road I
really do believe it's going to be a
tough road for these guys what would you
say if a teammate did that ye has a
right to to take this stance and and I
understand what he's trying to say i
would i would tell them you know
hopefully to first of all if i knew he
was going to do it if I knew he was
going to do it I would have got him I
would have told him to get out front to
make sure he makes his point on why he
is doing it you know because when I love
it I took of all the time man and i'm
told a story you do thursday night
football then I think I may have told
you and we watch i watch the wounded
warriors come out and hold on to that
flag during the national anthem you
watch these guys come out no without
limbs walking with their families and
how proud they are to hold that flag
when I see that flag I stand and that's
what I think about that's what I think
about and a lot of people think about
the people that are serving this country
not just the people that are in this
country that last [ __ ] nerds all around
we're all around this country but the
people that are serving this country
other things that I think about doing
this during the national anthem Anna and
I would have told him to make sure that
that doesn't get crossed up because I
think that's where some of his points it
gets lost in the whole thing because
everybody says now is you against the
military and I don't think he meant that
but that's still how it's being played
always great to talk to you Mike we look
forward to the upcoming season and
thanks for joining us BP it's good to
talk to you too man tell all your guys I
said hello DP and you guys you know I
lost our coach Alexander man my uh my
mentor and receivers coach for a lot of
years man I I know God probably don't
really listen to you guys but they'll
play anyway
uh I God is a big fan of this show Mike
I'm sure the fan motor show I don't know
about offender you guys well but thank
you mine thank you Mike match the Hall
of Famer the playmaker Michael Irvin the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience